dr carson for me you know one may say
uh uh fear is a great motivator right
fear sharpens listening when people are
afraid they listen when people are not
afraid they don't listen this is valid
in voting in marketing in sales
and
in pandemics and anything right so
but somebody from the left may say well
the right is selling fear that the
communists are trying to take over
america okay
then the left the right may sell
that the left is trying to control
america and you got to be very careful
because of you know what they're doing
you know they're they want to control
you
so which fear
should we be buying you know because the
left says the right is trying to go back
and take away all your freedoms and you
know take away women's rights and they
want to go back to what it was back in
the days and they may even take this
away from you and take that away from
you
both sides are selling the fear how does
the voter
sit there and say which fear is accurate
could they both be real is one fake who
do i trust i would say trust your eyes
and trust your ears
and trust your heart
you know open your eyes and see what's
going on
does it appear that people are trying to
indoctrinate our kids
what do you think
when uh they're telling
little boys and little girls you might
not be a little boy or a little girl
uh what are they trying to do when
they're telling kids that the most
important determinant
in your life is the color of your skin
when they're telling white kids that you
and your
ancestors are oppressors and are
responsible for others telling black
kids and minorities
that you
are victims
and you'll never be able to achieve
because of the way that this system is
set up
does that sound like indoctrination or
just benign chatter i don't think so
open your eyes and open your ears when
you know you're telling
and confusing children
childhood is supposed to be a time of
joy
and learning
and you're taking little kids and saying
do you think you're really a girl
are you you think you're really a boy
now children are naturally curious
and children are suggestible
so
you know
it's sort of like taking a
kindergartener
and trying to teach them calculus
they're not ready for that they're not
even close to ready for that that's very
abusive
or do you think maybe it's okay
you know open your eyes and open your
ears
and listen to your heart
you know that's not right
you know how hard it is uh
to do that because
when you open your eyes and you open
your ears 90 of the messaging is coming
from one place
so if i only take the counsel of open my
eyes and open my ears i'm only hearing
one side of the argument ninety percent
of time and that's why i said also
listen to your heart
people there are things that people for
instance
we know what a woman is
let's not let people confuse us about
we've known for
ever
since we've known about genetics
xx
woman
xy
man
end of story
but can you confuse people about it
absolutely so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
you